hey everyone my name is Carl Anthony
towns for the Timberwolves and this is
shoot your shot who is your favorite
basketball player growing up Magic
Johnson why was that he made his
teammates better Showtime flashy Ward
number 32 just like my dad Perfect combo
be Jersey guy Mount Rushmore Jersey
athletes maybe me Mike Trout Shaq Derek
Jeter if you could play one-on-one
against any NBA player in history who
would you choose and why I want to play
against Prime kg if you you could only
listen to One artist for the rest of
your life what artist would you choose
MC Miller who's one teammate that you
wouldn't want to play against nobody I
would like to play against anyone